en esta vivienda destruida se encontraba
agua ibrahim al hashemí al quraishi jefe
del grupo yihadista estado islámico
durante la madrugada en medio de un
operativo de las fuerzas estadounidenses
al quraishi uno de los hombres más
buscados del mundo símbolo detonando un
cinturón de explosivos
cuando nuestras tropas se acercaron para
capturar al terrorista en un acto final
de cobardía desesperada él sin tener en
cuenta las vidas de su propia familia y
otras personas del edificio optó por
inmolarse llevándose consigo a varios
miembros de su familia
al menos una docena de personas entre
ellos varios menores también murieron en
la explosión un helicóptero militar que
había sido utilizado para transportar
las tropas de las fuerzas especiales
desde hervir irak civil en la frontera
sirio turca último bastión de las
milicias rebeldes sirias también resultó
destruido
nos despertaron los ruidos de los
helicópteros hacía mucho tiempo que no
escuchábamos este tipo de sonidos los
residentes del campamento estaban muy
asustados porque estos sonidos les
recordaban los tiempos anteriores a
nuestro desplazamiento durante los
cuales el régimen de asad utilizaba
aviones helicópteros y bombas y para mí
se trata de la misión contra terroristas
ordenada por el pentágono más amplia
desde la caída del anterior jefe del
autodenominado estado islámico en 2019
la operación de anoche sacó a un
importante líder terrorista del campo de
batalla y envió un fuerte mensaje a los
terroristas de todo el mundo iremos por
ustedes y los encontraremos lejos de
desaparecer el grupo de estado islámico
sigue sembrando la violencia contra
civiles minorías y combatientes kurdos
en siria como lo demuestra el reciente
asalto de células durmientes alguna
cárcel con miles de reclusos yihadistas